[Music]
Donald Trump was expected to testify
under oath Wednesday as part of the New
York attorney general's civil probe into
the Trump family business good morning
the attorney general has said that she
has uncovered significant evidence that
the Trump organization used fraudulent
property values in representations that
made two Banks insurers and tax entities
and they have uncovered evidence that
the trumps were directly involved in
this New York attorney general Leticia
James sent subpoenas to Trump and two of
his adult children Ivanka Trump and
Donald Trump Jr in December ordering
them to testify in closed-door
depositions the trumps have denied
wrongdoing the interview comes on the
heels of federal agents searching his
Florida residence Monday for a separate
investigation by the justice department
Corrine Ramey covers white-collar crime
for the Wall Street Journal and explains
what you need to know about the New York
attorney general's civil investigation
[Music]
the Attorney General's office has said
its probe began in March 2019 after
former Trump lawyer Michael Cohen
testified before Congress it was my
experience that Mr Trump inflated his
total assets when it served his purposes
such as trying to be listed amongst the
wealthiest people in Forbes and deflated
his assets
to reduce his real estate taxes Attorney
General James's office has since said
that Donald Trump made inaccurate
statements in financial documents for
multiple Properties by inflating his
assets this could lead to more favorable
terms from lenders or insurers it could
lead to bigger loans in 2015 and 2016
Trump's financial statements valued his
Triplex apartment in Trump Tower at 327
million dollars based on the assertion
that the triplex was 30 000 square feet
in size the Attorney General says the
actual size of the apartment was 10 996
square feet and that Trump even signed
documents confirming this in 2012.
according to the attorney general Alan
weisselberg the Chief Financial Officer
also admitted the value of the apartment
was overstated by 200 million the
Attorney General also says Trump falsely
valued Seven Springs a 213 acre property
in Westchester County New York that the
former president bought for 7.5 million
dollars in 1995 5. the Trump
organization had considered developing
the property but later scrapped the
plans Trump instead placed 158 Acres of
the land in a conservation easement
conservation easements are donating the
Land Development rights for a property
in exchange for tax benefits the
conservation easement portion of the
land was appraised at 21.1 million
dollars in 2016. and a lawyer for the
Attorney General's office said Seven
Springs LLC which is part of the Trump
organization claimed a 21.1 million
dollar tax deduction for the easement in
tax year 2015. it was higher than
previous valuations this allowed him to
get a larger tax benefit according to
the attorney general a spokeswoman for
the Trump organization said attorney
general James's allegations were
baseless and the trumps have claimed
that the subpoenas could be used to
improperly gather evidence for a
separate criminal investigation by the
Manhattan district attorney which has
led to indictments charging the Trump
organization and its Finance
Alan weiselberg with tax crimes that
investigation is continuing and it has
looked at similar issues in terms of
deflating and inflating assets lawyers
for the trumps also argued that the
office of Attorney General James a
Democrat had unfairly targeted the
former president and his children for
political reasons they point to
statement she made during her campaign
when she has said she'll investigate the
trumps and sort of made this a campaign
priority the trumps had attempted to
avoid testifying by asking courts to
quash the subpoenas but the courts ruled
in favor of the Attorney General and
said that the subpoenas were valid so
the trumps ran out of legal options and
now they need to testify Warriors for
the New York attorney general have
indicated that they could file a civil
lawsuit but it's unclear who the
defendants would be it could be the
Trump organization it could be Trump
himself or other company Executives or
employees it could be his kids typically
these lawsuits they take several years
to go through the courts and they it
could end in a settlement or a trial and
typically the penalties are Financial
foreign
[Music]